hey everyone it's my vatos and welcome
to this little presentation on the
Balto's snr levels for November 17 2017
now on Friday right the 17th I did a
presentation with investor inspiration
on support and resistance and you know I
want to follow it up with this this this
quick little video just highlighting
some of the day's activity in the in the
markets with the support and resistance
levels and you know I didn't really
showed a couple charts of the in real
time in the presentation but you know I
just want to follow up with a couple
other markets so there's some
interesting thing I talked about crude
in the presentation alive but I didn't
talk about the e-mini z meetings were
interesting and there's one of the
markets which I wanted to jump into
really quick but before I get started
brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or making another type of
investment decision and investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital as money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading and only those were sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
best for it's not necessarily indicative
of future results now the tools I use in
this presentation is the bottles SNR
levels and it runs on ninjatrader seven
and ninjatrader a core working on a fix
for the NinjaTrader eight version a few
people have been reporting some issues
with it and I really hope you get that
sorted out ASAP so just be patient if
you're on NT eight but it runs perfectly
fine on NT seven but anyway let's let's
just jump into these markets really
quick okay so the first mark on top of
all is crude and this is a four range
chart and you know if you trade on a
four range chart you're gonna be in and
out of the market very often actually
and this is this is how it's looked
since I mean I'll just take it from you
know I mean I had you know gosh well
this is the reopen and this is five five
o'clock at on the 16th and you can see
it gave a couple little cells here it
didn't really work out there great but
again you know that that's what time is
that that's you know one to a 2 a.m.
they got this big move you get your
swing high here we sell off you got a
buy here that failed by your
failed a small cell here just went
sideways
a nice little cell here this by failed
this by just went sideways you know a
quick cell here for you know 5 10 ticks
another cell here another you know 15
ticks more or less a little by here that
I don't know what you would have got out
of that then you got then you run into
this area here we get a bye boom you get
support runs right up into resistance
cells off to support level back up to
resistance keeps going up here you hit
the resistance to sell off sell off a
little bit here make a new high just
sort of go sideways this buy fails I
mean it starts going up then it fails
then you get this nice little buy here
rallies up to resistance cells off back
down to support rallies back up to
resistance again sells off
there's no buy signal and on this at
this point but again you're coming down
into an area where you got support right
you've got any support here support here
in the order flow you know it would look
beautiful if it showed up there you know
it just didn't but you already know how
you got support there so you could sort
of anticipate it right that's that's
what you want to be doing as a trader
you want to be anticipating you know
that that's that's the thing that I
talked about in that webinar is you know
most traders you know the part that they
miss out on is okay so you got this move
here right from you sell off from this
this high here you get down here you
have support you rally up to resistance
you sell off now there's just a couple
ways you could trade it one you don't
know you know that you're gonna have
resistance here you might thinking
you're just gonna keep going higher but
you hit this area of resistance and it
prints there right the indicator prints
so you know you could be throwing in
offers here so that if you retest it you
could be getting short right rather than
waiting for it to retest it I then start
selling off and you're getting short
down here you know 10 ticks lower just
as you know you got your buy here you
got your support in this level your
rally up okay well what are you gonna do
you're gonna work bids you know your
staff bids down in here you know from
around this level a little bit ahead of
it down through it or down to the bottom
of it so if it does pull back you could
get long
all right you don't need to wait for a
confirmation in the market to start to
move up say well you know we got a
double bottom here I should be buying
you know that that's the move you want
this is the move you want all right a
lot of people they wait for confirmation
wait for confirmation
famous last words what are you doing I'm
waiting for confirmation and
confirmation never comes sometimes now
the e-mini Ximenes were very interesting
here this morning
I'm sorry Friday morning and you know
just taking it back here a bit you know
since this is here 8:50 a.m. what do you
got you got a resistance level I mean
okay you poked through it by the tick it
doesn't necessarily mean that a it's the
end of the world a we poked through it
by a tick you know it's it's not really
resistance it's it's resistance
you know and what you do is sold off you
sold off down to a support level what
you know you rally back up towards the
resistance area now in this case the
resistance just happened to be the
opening price which you know if if your
start training around opening prices is
a sign that the markets going sideways
you know they wanna do it you sell-off
back down to support okay there's
another case where you do you do to
overshoot it by I don't know what that
is about a half a point and then you
rally back up to where you rally back up
to the resistance area a little bit
later in the day again it gives another
signal there anyway you already know
that's your resistance at that point and
what do you do you just drift back down
back down back down a little bit later
two o'clock you get a lower resistance
level and then you sell off some more
down into new lows for the day so you
know there's a range base day more or
less you know basically between 78 and
you know 82 and a half but you know when
you're trading right you have to have
more than one style right you have to be
prepared to trade in range-bound markets
like you saw here in the SPS
you know crude oil even though you were
going higher you know we do we run into
parts where we're just you know trading
in a range like this boom boom boom you
know yet you had some some moves up some
trends up you know we were on a we were
on an up move here right and you get
another buy signal there you know these
cells yeah they weren't so hot
but you know what the buy is more than
made up for it and then when you're
sitting here in this range bound market
you know you get by cell by cell
you know it's it's one right after the
other so you should have and you should
have a way of catching reversals
catching range bound markets and
catching um you know trends when they're
occurring okay now this one I want to
show you it's a little bit more I'll say
advanced but you know if you're using
the Delta scalper and in the SNR levels
what do you want to be looking for right
that's the question is what you want to
look for first is the SR levels to give
a sign okay because you can put it in
support or you're putting in resistance
okay so like here you have a cell on the
snr levels you got somebody i'm not
concerned with those because i'm just
looking at it in relation to delta
scalper so I don't know if I could draw
here what do I want
yeah do this okay so here whoops so you
have this one so you got the Delta
scalper right here about five bars after
you get the signal for the SNR levels
then you got a nice sell-off why because
what you're looking for right you're
looking for the resistance level that we
put in then you're looking for the Delta
to confirm it with you know with strong
aggressive sellers you know in this case
you have the resistance level put in you
do poke a little bit higher past the
resistance level okay before the strong
selling finally comes back in and it's
coming back in around you know in this
bar which is right around that
resistance level and then you sell off
you sell off from you know what is that
one eighteen thirty down to one eighteen
ten kind of goes sideways you got
another one here you got the resistance
level with the Delta scalper cell and
what happens one bar two bars three bars
you're going sideways okay it kind of
sucks but you know that that's what
happens sometimes then you know so then
it pops back up here stops you out here
you got a or is it right here
you got to buy lose this support
level then you got the Dell to the
scalper kicking in it right on the next
bar you do go up and then you come back
down test that support level before
finally making the move that you want
okay you know so you got one
yes debatable if this would have stopped
you out I mean you're only talking I
mean again I don't know where you'd want
to place your stop if you you know
bottom of this bar is ninety two and a
half we didn't wanted to trade down to
91 and a half so cow
wonderful tic through here you know but
you know what can you do you know this
one definitely was would have stopped
you out this one no you would have got
in fine really what you want you want
the move to happen as as soon as the
Delta scalper kicks in you don't want to
start seeing it go sideways on you you
know this one's starting to go up then
it sort of reversed back down okay then
just really quick I just want to show
you the Nasdaq this is the Nasdaq this
is an eight range chart
you got a support level here well what
happens we get a nice little rally here
come back in take off the support put in
a new low rally I put in a new low what
do you do you got a support level down
here your rally up to a resistance level
sell-off towards the support area rally
back up through the resistance level and
what do you get you get another sell
signal right here right at the same
level you know I love these where you
get the the resistance coming in again
or support coming in you know at a
previous level all right so you had it
here all something's coming back in
because you know what's happening okay
you got sellers coming in here we
sell-off rally back up to this area and
it's at that area where and say hey you
know what this is a good area sell
because they were selling earlier you
know all in here and then what happens
you sell off again come down to another
support level what happens is your rally
back up you know from this low here 63
20s you know the below is four and three
quarters but you know essentially for
the next bar is like 26 27 and back up
to where 36 37 and even in here you've
got a support level
you know which draw it over you getting
another support level here it's not the
biggest move up but again still it's
still a decent move about a three or
four points another support area down in
here rally back up resistance level
coming in here sell-off down into the
support area then this one just breaks
apart right here and then we sell-off
into new lows and then you end up
closing the day so you know it was an
interesting day that was actually for
markets but yeah I wanted you to see
that so you know you can understand you
know why is yet to be able to trade and
in different types of market conditions
right you know because the markets don't
always range trade they don't always
trend they don't always reverse you know
I mean the reversals are where you gonna
make the big money I think I mean I see
big money the reversals are where you
gonna get the big moves trends yeah you
don't always catch the trend but I mean
you know reversals we're gonna catch the
trend beginning you get in a trend you
know the way I trade trends is you know
I just get in get out you know get in
right if what you can and then get out
and of course range holidays right you
know range bound periods it's like yes
apiece you know it was range bound but
you could have got you know trading in
that range you know there was a big day
as far as activity up and down but you
know you could have got 8 9 points out
of that day points not ticks so um you
know it and the presentation I had I had
a special special price offer this is
the link for it you know it expires
Sunday night I may have to extend it
until Monday because I didn't get the
webinar replay and you know because the
presentations were on Friday and they
ended kind of late I think like 4:30 or
5 o'clock in the afternoon and you know
people have put the presentation they
just haven't had a time to get me the
link before the weekend which is you
know understand well usually when you're
doing on Friday I don't get it till
Monday so I I may extend it a day but
you know if you want to get in um you
get the indicator and I'm gonna also
give a special members-only presentation
covering some of the
other uses for the indicator with with
other trading tools you know some of my
other indicators as well so it'll be on
Wednesday before Thanksgiving on the
22nd at 7:00 p.m. Central time so it's
definitely you know definitely a decent
tool that you could add for your trading
even if you have an existing way of
trading
it's um excuse me it's something that
you know is worthwhile definitely so
thanks and I hope to see you guys on
Wednesday bye bye